hello oh hey no that doesn't count you  got a text no t they said to call him  ASAP why would he not just call you if  it's an emergency I do something wrong  [Music]  did you VIN will the wrong Steve again  maybe he like won the lottery  you think so you know what if you got  somebody pregnant oh [ __ ] what he did  somehow you bring it it may be just like  car trouble yeah exactly what if it is  car trouble  I mean it's not like he's in jail he's  arguing with the neighbors again stupid  parties where you're up on that I don't  think [ __ ] damn did I leave the gas on  maybe you need milk maybe  rah digga kidnap maybe listen to my  mixtape when's the last time you called  them anyway yo what's up you okay yeah  seriously all right it's a syrup  sandwich four nine zero no no that's too  long he just texted to me